دبابة في جبال نوسا
الطريق ويوجهك
إلى المنزل لم أكن أعتقد أنني سأرى نعم أرى مصورًا
انت
وكان من المأمول أن يكون هناك بعض إطلاق النار
واو، أولاً وقبل كل شيء، إنها مروحية تابعة للشرطة، آسف
قلت هال الهواء هقولك جي ايه
من الصعب في هذه الحالة أن يكون إطلاق النار مبررًا
نعم هناك ادعاء باسمها بدأوا يرونه في الرماة
داخل المنزل ولا فائدة من مواصلة الحديث معهم
أزل الشيء المزعج الذي لا أحد يحقق معك
هذا الحدث مليء بعلامات الاستفهام
ومن الصعب أن أعتقد أن على شخص ما أن يعطينا
إجراء تحقيق منظم لما يعرفونه أن مثل هذا الحدث يحتاج
استجوابه بالمناسبة سيكون أكبر كارثة
نفس الشيء هنا وسنتوصل إلى استنتاج مفاده أن جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي يحتجز نويل
ويقرر هاني بيل قتل بعض الخاطفين مقابل الحصول على شاهد
كم عدد الإرهابيين للأسف، أنا متأكد من أنه ليس كذلك
يلجأ بعض الوزراء إلى رئيس الأركان ويخبرونه
متى سنرى الإنجاز الإنجاز جلب المخطوف
والقضاء على قدرة حماس على القضاء على انتخابات رئاسة الأركان
إجابات تؤذي الاختيار يستغرق الأمر وقتًا في الرأس
استغرق بن لادن 10 سنوات لجلب كبار العمال إلى هنا
إنه معروف للشعب، وسوف يستغرق أقل بكثير من ليفين
لقد دخلنا غزة بحيث يستغرق القضاء عليها 10 سنوات
أنت مثير، سوف يستغرق الأمر 10 سنوات حيث سيكون آرا ريجيف هنا
لرؤية جيش الوزراء كوهين ليفين وجملائيل
معًا سنكون هنا لمدة 10 سنوات وعشر سنوات أخرى
كان ينبغي على ريغيف أن يأتي بها منذ فترة طويلة، قبل عشر سنوات
هذا هو النقاش الذي دار بالأمس في مجلس الوزراء على ما أعتقد
أنه في النهاية وزراء الحكومة وأعتقد أيضًا وزراء الحكومة
نحن نفهم أن الجمهور في الخارج يراقب ويريد ذلك
أرى إنجازًا كبيرًا يحقق وعيي الآن جميعًا
الإنجازات التي نراها في ساحة المعركة نحن
لا يمكن دائمًا لحام ورق المواصفات والمواصفات
في صورة ما أسميناها صورة النصر
فيأتي السيريم ويسألون متى سيحدث ويقولون
بالنسبة لهم رئيس الأركان بصراحة لا أعرف يائير أنسباخر
أنه يحقق في طبيعة النظام الأمني ​​الذي يستخدمه الرجل
حضور مهيمن جدًا أمس جدًا
منزعج، انتبه هنا أنا هنا بعد ذلك
بلفور ماعون رئيس الوزراء الوقح الذي يعرض للخطر البلاد
لقد أعلن عن حياة جندينا بكل وقاحة
غدة هذه الدمى الأمريكية بعد الزيارة
من أوستن هناك سيعودون غزة غزة بهم
لقد قاتلوا هناك، واحتلوا منزلك، بيت غزة
هذا صحيح، إنها ملكك يا بيبي، وأنت لست كذلك
من العار أنهم يريدون إعطائها الآن
لكي يعود الفلسطينيون للفلسطينيين انا هنا ميش
الرجل الذي سيأتي همس موجود من جنوب قطاع غزة
نحال بيشور وجنوب حمص هو العنوان ويعمل
ومن المرجح أن هناك بلديات تعمل بلديا و ض
بالتأكيد لا يزال هامز موجودًا هناك ونحن نبحث بالفعل
شجعت الأيام الطويلة المشاعر التي أود أن أقولها
ويجب أن يقال هذا مع الجمهور الغزاوي المناهض للحامسي
إنها موجودة، لكنها صغيرة جدًا، هذه هي الحقيقة
الشخص المحزن سيقول أنني لا أفعل ذلك